but when I had to go meet Al Pacino I'm
like that he said meet him on Shutters
on the Beach and I'm like oh you
know right so I go down and when I get
in there he's sitting like under like a
dim lit like they had him lit in the
restaurant like everybody else
was just everybody else is in the yard
had some shade on his face
and and I walked up I said damn
that's scarf out there that's Scarface
and Godfather right so I walked up to
him I said hello Mr Pacino I just you
know how are you you like cranberry
juice I was like what the he says
they got great cranberry juice here and
I was like oh
and I saw how great of an actor he was
and the fact that he's nothing like
those characters that's what lets you
know he's special like when you see D
out D is still D you see Denzel all
right what's up all right what's going
on all right okay what we doing tonight
oh this still you know he still
didn't say it is that right Al Pacino is
nothing like the character he's talking
about cranberry juice he was a little
unsure of himself at points